la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame 50 négociations
politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre va perdre gros là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est-ce que les chaussons totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
les 14 députés et sénateurs réunis en
commission mixte paritaire sont parvenus
à un accord de principe
le projet de loi qui est en usage du pas
salutaire et andros l'obligation dexia
le soignant devrait donc sauf surprise
être définitivement adopté dans la
soirée un texte d'origine
gouvernementale approuvé par l'assemblée
nationale largement modifié par le sénat
un texte controversé qui a conduit hier
près de 161 me protestataires a
manifesté un peu partout en france
[Musique]
il réclame la destitution de jaillir
bolt au maroc pour le quatrième week end
consécutif des dizaines de milliers de
brésiliens ont à nouveau manifesté à
l'appel des partis de gauche et des
syndicats
alors que l'épidémie a fait plus de cinq
cent mille morts dans le pays ils
reprochent au président brésilien sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire
j'ai un bol simaro visé par une enquête
sur d'éventuelles irrégularités dans la
négociation de vaccins anti peut vivre
[Musique]
un dimanche marquée par la grande parade
annuelle de la pétrusse que les
festivités se sont déroulées à saint
pétersbourg en présence de vladimir
poutine
défilé des navires les plus performants
une aviation navale des systèmes de
défense des armes hypersonique qui n'ont
pas d'équivalent dans le monde selon
président russe estime que la russie a
gagné sa place parmi les principales
puissances maritimes mondiales
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france le projet de loi
sur la gestion de la crise sanitaire sur
le pont d'être définitivement adoptée
chute députés et sénateurs ont trouvé un
compromis chez au terme d'une réunion de
près de trois heures en commission mixte
paritaire
après l'assemblée nationale le sénat
dominé par l'opposition droite a adopté
le texte hier mais après y avoir apporté
plusieurs modifications comme
l'exemption du pas salutaire pour les
mineurs ou en terrasse le passage du ter
juges élus mmes liberticide par les
quelques 161 1030 protestataires qui ont
manifesté un peu partout en france ce
samedi ils étaient 2000 dans la capitale
toujours selon in-stat l'intérieur paris
où 24 personnes ont été interpellées de
la mise en oeuvre de salt i elle de
décider librement pour ce qui le
concerne c'est non nous l'appelons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on attend de mettre un petit peu
apprécié son gouvernement et de leur
dire que bien énormément de français de
plus en plus nombreux qui refuse c'est
pas sanitaire qui veut nous imposer et
qui veulent simplement garder leur
liberté
mais aujourd'hui la triche ouais c'est
pas possible ça se passe
le fait de nous priver de nos libertés
de mouvement à partir du moment où
ne pourra pas présenter un pass
sanitaire je trouve ça je trouve ça d'un
scandale absolu
contre sanitaires
[Musique]
de l'info
[Applaudissements]
la france où le virus continue de se
propager près de 23 mille nouveaux cas
de contamination recensés en 24 heures
en ile-de-france le responsable de
l'agencé régionale de santé tire la
sonnette d'alarmé en moins d'une semaine
le taux d'incidence a doublé dans la
région
une situation inquiétante pour les
hôpitaux alors que les effectifs de
soignants sont réduits en cette période
estivale les soignants qui ont reçu la
visite des manuels macron fera papeete
le chef de l'état est arrivé à tahiti ce
matin dans la foulée schyle a visité le
principal hôpital
emmanuel macron qui a exhorté les
polynésiens et l'enfant des français à
se faire vacciner mon message était et
est simple et repose au tour de de
conviction qui valent pour la polynésie
française mais pour l'ensemble du
territoire français la première c'est
que nous avons une arme qu'il faut
utiliser qui est le vaccin
le vaccin est ici largement disponibles
et plusieurs centaines de milliers de
doses qui ne sont pas utilisés et qu'il
faut continuer à utiliser mais partout
nous devons nous faire vacciner visite
de quatre jours au cours de laquelle
sera abordée la question sensible des
conséquences ne laissait nucléaires
menées de 1966 à 1996 en polynésie
les membres de l'association 193 qui
représente des victimes attendent des
excuses écoutez nous attendons du
résident une demande de pardon
tout comme il a reconnu comme crime la
colonisation qui s'est déroulé en un
jury nous attendons qui détient 10 était
criminel et que c'est cette forme d'une
colonisation lyon nucléaire lycée dans
le pacifique
ce n'est pas une question de sous les
hanter comme des quémandeurs permanent
ce pays a besoin d'être pacifiée d'être
réconcilié avec lui même et ses
habitants il ya un combat de ces l'état
français parce que c'est pas nous qui
avons six ans c'est la france c'est
beaucoup
à redon c'est suffisant ses ennemis et
pour daniel 1 d'allan président du
conseil représentatif des français
d'outre-mer il ne faut pas s'attendre à
des excuses de la part de la france on
écoute
il me semble que la france nous ne
demandera pas pardon
peut-être qu'elle fera des actions ou re
à la marge ou une prise néo prise en
compte des personnes à part le par les
différents cancers mais le menu attendre
le pardon de la france de manière
distincte
ce serait vraiment ce serait vraiment
exceptionnel il ne faut pas emmener
melun où que mais les autres mais a plus
que je suis le président des français
considèrent que nous a fait défaut c'est
bien il ne faut pas oublier que la
france doit beaucoup à ses 12 premières
au 1er mai si elle a su parfaire son
bouclier public dans la caraïbe et là
aussi elle maintient sa présence face à
tout ça dans le respect de
condescendance nolita plus que les gens
ont l'impression que nous sommes du
quémandeur nous sommes des demandeurs et
finalement si la france qui nous nous
sommes donc je ne m'attends pas à ce que
le président n'avait qu'une ils
demandent purement et simplement
peut-être va-t-il annoncer demain la
marche
l'épidémie de kobe 19 en pleine
résurgence en thaïlande de 15 mille
nouveaux cas ont été enregistrés ce
dimanche entre easter record alors que
la vaccination piétine le pays semble
dépassé par la propagation du variant
delta à les hôpitaux sont débordés
conduisant un groupe de bénévoles a
arpenté le quartier de sa maille à
bangkok pour aider les personnes dans le
besoin
quentin mauclair vêtus de combinaisons
et visage masqué ce groupe de
volontaires s'apprête à rendre visite à
des malades du coït 19
une fois les bouteilles d'oxygène poser
dans le coffre des voitures
les voilà partis au secours des
personnes isolées chez elles
faute de lits disponibles dans les
hôpitaux nous réalisons à quel point les
médecins et les infirmières travaillent
dur et sont fatigués ce connaissions le
faire aujourd'hui c'est de les soulager
d'une partie de ce fardeau en les aidant
le nombre de nouveaux cas journalier de
covin 19 ne cesse de franchir des
nouveaux records ces derniers jours dans
ce logement une femme allongée en
difficulté respiratoire n'a pas pu
consulter un médecin
son mari a multiplié les appels aux
hôpitaux mais aucun n'a pu répondre à sa
demande
l'homme a donc décidé de solliciter
l'aide du groupe de bénévoles
j'ai perdu tout espoir même avec l'armée
j'ai appelé les hôpitaux de campagne
tout ce qu'ils m'ont dit c'est d'envoyer
des informations justes des informations
j'ai eu la même réponse partout au moins
ces gars viennent me voir chez nous ce
dont le patient a besoin c'est de voir
un médecin pas d'envoyer des
informations le groupe de volontaires
reçoit une centaine d'appels d'urgence
par jour venant de malades désespérée
dans la capitale thaïlandaise
la situation est critique l'ensemble des
lits des hôpitaux sont occupés au moins
vingt mille patients attendrait qu'une
place se libère
ma mère a présenté des symptômes sévères
dès le début j'ai appelé est rappelé
pour leur dire que ma mère ne pouvait
plus faire face à cela mais personne
n'est venu
les infirmières répétait sans cesse
qu'il n'y avait pas de lits disponibles
les records de nouvelles infections
quotidiennes sont dues à la propagation
exponentielle du vaillant delta dans le
pays
la situation semble d'autant plus hors
de contrôle que la vaccination tourne au
ralenti à travers le territoire
seul un peu plus de 5% de la population
sont entièrement vacciner nouveau
week-end de manifestations au brésil
dans le collimateur des protestataires
le chef de l'état décrié pour sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire locaux vides a
fait plus de cinq cent mille morts dans
le pays
la faute selon lui à jaillir un bol
sonar aux visées par ailleurs par une
enquête
il aurait fermé les yeux dans une
affaire de corruption liée à l'achat de
vaccins anti qu'ovide le récit de yamina
benguigui d'un sonar au-dehors plus
jamais de dictature ce sont les mots
scandés par des manifestants qui sont
sortis massivement dans les rues c'est
le quatrième week-end de manifestations
cette fois plus de 500 vivent se sont
joints à l élan contestataire à l'appel
des partis de gauche et des syndicats
et que ce soit à rio brasilia ou sao
paulo les motivations restent les mêmes
et parmi elles l'éviction du président
du zaïre paul sonar au critiqué
notamment pour n'avoir connu que
tardivement l'importance de la pandémie
qui a déjà tué près de 550 milles
brésilien et pour une campagne de
vaccination laborieuse et incohérentes
je suis ici pour que les gens sachent
que nous vivons dans un gouvernement
négationnistes
les vaccins aurait dû arriver depuis
longtemps beaucoup de familles ont perdu
des personnes des parents des amis
autre critique exprimée contre le
président brésilien
sa gestion politique et économique du
pays les manifestants demandent plus de
démocratie et la fin du chômage
je suis ici à cause de ce gouvernement
que nous voulons renverser un
gouvernement fasciste psychopathe
génocidaire qui a tué plus de personnes
proportionnellement dans le monde le
nombre de personnes qui se sont
appauvris et il détruit tous les droits
du travail le gouvernement ball sonar ou
est accusé de corruption au congrès pour
des soupçons de pots de vin dans le
cadre de l'achat de vaccins contre le
coc vie de 19
une accusation qui s'ajoute à une longue
liste d'irrégularités présumées son fils
flavio boltro narrow également sénateur
a pris la défense du président quelques
jours plus tôt juste après avoir reçu sa
première dose de vaccin grâce au
président ball sonar aux 164 millions de
doses ont déjà été distribués à ce jour
le négationniste garantit le vaccin dans
les bras de tous les brésiliens
le nom de l'ancien président lula à
paresser sur les tee-shirts et pancartes
ils sont plusieurs à réclamer son retour
au pouvoir
l'opposition a présenté le 30 juin une
plainte en destitution constitué de 20
accusations différentes contre djair
bolson araud mais le chef d'état dispose
toujours de suffisamment de soutiens au
congrès pour bloquer ces initiatives
et malgré la défiance d'une grande
partie de la population le président
brésilien restera au pouvoir jusqu'aux
prochaines élections c'est la vie driss
galy spécialiste en relations
internationales
bosson arrow est toujours soutenue comme
vous l'avez dit par une grande partie du
congrès et pas une trentaine de pour
cent de l'opinion publique aux fins de
selon les sondages qui est à fond pour
ressort donc vous avez oublié qu'il est
très très divisés très polarisée et
finalement je pense qu'il faut attendre
des élections de l'an prochain 2022
d'ici là il y aura beaucoup de bruit
mais je vois mal le président être être
destitué tomber sauf cataclysme
évidemment le problème des gens qui
montent or aujourd'hui dans le brésil
ce n'est pas celui-là c'est l'inflation
l'accrocheur lisation les enfants qui ne
vont pas à l'école depuis deux ans c'est
ça vraiment j'ai l'impression qu'ils
seraient levées les plaies de lenôtre
quotidien et je vois ces manifestations
sont complètement dans un monde
je dirais pas qu'il n'existe pas mais ce
sont des propos qui sont journée de
manifestations en tunisie siens
l'occasion de la fête nationale
rassemblements dans plusieurs villes du
pays pour protester contre la gestion de
la pandémie et dénoncer une crise
politique qui paralysait le pays depuis
plusieurs mois ont toute notre
correspondant bassin chebbi
bonsoir bassem un appel à manifester qui
a circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
comment s'est passée cette journée quel
était l'objectif des manifestants
bonsoir sauf si effectivement ça fait
quelques jours déjà que jean vient se
prépare pour descendre dans la rue
notamment par rapport à la recrudescence
des cas d'accord lundi rue en tunisie et
la gestion chaotique du gouvernement
avec une campagne de vaccination qui
piétine et qui a eu du mal à décoller
avant de pouvoir commencer grâce à
l'aide internationale et puis avec des
confirmands à répétition des consignes
qui ne sont pas toujours très claire des
choses qui ont été mises en place par le
gouvernement que les tunisiens ne
comprennent toujours pas et puis à toute
cette crise de sa litière qui a été
notamment enflammé grossi par une crise
de politique dure en tunisie depuis a
très longtemps un conflit entre le
président de la république et son
premier ministre ainsi que les
parlementaires cet appel à manifester a
été véhiculée à travers les réseaux
sociaux
et puis plusieurs milliers de
manifestants ont répondu présent des
centaines à travers toutes les villes
notamment à tunis à sfax à 40 du nord au
sud n'y a pas une grande ville de la
tunisie qui n'a pas répondu présents
pour cette manifestation est déjà très
tôt de piste ce matin des barrages ont
été mises en place sur la capitale tunis
qui a été complètement quadrillée
objectifs de la police maintenir le
coeur de la capitale vide est sous
contrôle pour barre avoir un afflux de
manifestants c'est autour de bach
d'autres vers le parlement que les
tunisiens se sont donné rendez vous les
tunisiens de la capitale dans d'autres
villes étaient nombreux à se rassembler
l'équipe l'otan était clairement hostile
au parti ennahda le parti islamiste au
pouvoir que les manifestants accusent
d'être à la tête de tous les maux de la
société notamment au niveau de la crise
économique que traverse le pays
il demande très clairement la
dissolution du parlement les tunisiens
font pas tig et de ses guerres
partisanes qu'il ya en tunisie et qui
empêche tout de réforme tout changement
ou toute avancée il y avait clamé
également une nouvelle constitution et
que s'arrête enfin ces querelles au sein
même du gouvernement
dans certaines villes du pays étaient
bureau du parti ennahda ont même été
saccagés il ya eu une certaine tension
des heurts entre manifestants et
policiers notamment à tunis où la police
a fait usage de bombes de gaz
lacrymogène pour disperser
population et les manifestants certaines
arrestations un journaliste avait été
blessée
le calme est revenu dans l'après-midi
mais apparemment certains manifestants
ont décidé peut-être de redescendre
encore ce soir ils vont confier que
c'était une première journée de colère
et de manifestation et qu'il fallait
s'attendre à d'autres mouvements de
telle ampleur pour que le gouvernement
puisse enfin réagir prenne ses
responsabilités face à la situation
chaotique sanitaire économique dans
laquelle se trouve la tunisie bassam
chebbi pour ces précisions merci
beaucoup à faire
les états unis poursuivront leurs
frappes aériennes en afghanistan si
l'offensive des talibans on continue
déclaration ce soir du chef des
opérations militaires américaines dans
le pays alors qu'un couvre-feu a été
décrété sur l'ensemble du territoire
seules trois provinces dont celle de
kaboul ne sont pas concernés par la
mesure
le gouvernement afghan n'a pas précisé
sa durée d'application objectifs de ces
autorités endiguer l'offensive des
insurgés lancé en mai dernier alors que
le retrait des forces étrangères a est
pratiquement terminé de nombreux afghans
disent comprendre les précautions prises
par leurs dirigeants écouter avant le
couvre-feu
il y avait la foule et les gens avec
leur famille venait jusqu'à minuit et
une heure du matin
mais depuis la nuit dernière lorsque le
couvre-feu a été annoncé les gens ont
peur et ne sortent plus il n'y a plus
personne
les dernières nuits quand il n'y avait
pas de couvre-feu les gens et les
commerçants sortait et les marchés
étaient animés
mais depuis ce soir 22h nous voyons
moins en moins de gens ils ne sont pas
bouclées les marchés sont vides et il ya
moins de trafic les gens respectent le
couvre-feu la russie célébrait ce
dimanche les 3 125 ans de la marine
russe
les plus beaux rêves navires ont défilé
dans la baie de saint pétersbourg en
présence de vladimir poutine
compte rendu de l'événement avec notre
correspondante one les roe tout a
commencé avec l'arrivée de vladimir
poutine il a dans un premier temps salué
les différents navires qui sont
stationnés derrière moi comme une
frégate qui se trouve à ma droite ou
encore la corvette story qui que vous
pouvez voir juste derrière moi il a
ensuite débarqué il a rejoint la tribune
présidentielle d'où il s'est exprimé
pour une prise de parole à destination
des marins je vous propose d'en écouter
un extrait aujourd'hui la marine us tout
ce qu'il faut pour garantir la défense
de notre patrie nos internationaux
elle est capable de découvrir tout
navire en surface ou en profondeur qui
s'approcherait de notre pays ait résisté
à tous les coups qui peuvent lui être
reporté
et c'est seulement à l'issue de ce
discours qu'a pu réellement débuté la
parade navale alors cette parade s'est
déroulée en trois temps un premier temps
avec le défilé ici sur la neva au niveau
de la ville de saint pétersbourg une
vingtaine de bateaux ont ainsi remonté
le fleuve dans un second temps le défilé
pour les navires plus imposant ainsi que
les sous marins qui lui s'est déroulée
un peu plus au large de saint
pétersbourg au niveau de l'île de
cronstadt et enfin troisième partie avec
le volet aérien de cette parade 48
avions et hélicoptères qui ont survolé
l'île de cronstadt et la ville de saint
pétersbourg propose de revenir avec un
officier de la marine sur le déroulé des
événements
si vous ne voyez donc aujourd'hui c'est
l' orchestre navals conjoints
j'ai composé de plusieurs ensembles
serait bien participer au défilé navale
principal collectif sont les meilleurs
ensembles de la marine tous ces
musiciens se sont préparés bien à l'as
vence pour le défilé d'abord ils ont
travaillé leur répertoire
individuellement voulait plus que nous
sommes réunis en un grand orchestre du
combiné et chaque jour nous nous
préparions pour le défilé d'aujourd'hui
cette édition 2021 marque donc le 325e
anniversaire de la marine russe la
marine russe fondée à la toute fin du
xviie siècle par le tsar pierre le grand
direction la part les états unis chant
des partisans de donald trump ont
organisé une collecte de fonds un
événement qui s'est déroulé à auburn
dans le massachusetts à l'initiative du
groupe d'ultra droite américain super
happy sean la plupart des participants
auraient participé à l'assaut du
capitole 6 janvier dernier face aux
accusations d' appels à la haine à
l'insurrection
les membres de ce mouvement se défendent
et assurent être persécutés par le fbi
dans les semaines qui ont suivi le 6
janvier ma vie a été complètement
chamboulée d'abord j'ai perdu mon emploi
presque sûr parce que l'edf s'est rendu
dans mon entreprise
ensuite j'ai été arrêté je suis resté en
prison pendant trois jours j'ai attendu
d'être libéré et pendant ce temps ils
ont effectué des perquisitions chez moi
ils ont saccagé ma maison les flics tout
plu à faire pendant environ huit heures
ils n'ont rien trouvé d'autre les
récents et plus de six mois après les
événements la justice son plat
aujourd'hui à juger les personnes
arrêtées
une première condamnation pénale a été
prononcée lundi
les précisions notre correspondant à
washington abonnés c'était il ya plus de
six mois le capitole investi par
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
les participants doivent maintenant
répondre de leurs actes
la justice arrêté environ 550 personnes
la plupart ayant eu le temps de rentrer
chez eux avant finalement d'être
interpellé
ce chiffre pourrait augmenter puisque
selon certaines estimations
ils étaient 800 à être entré dans le
capitole le 6 janvier dernier
[Applaudissements]
nous envisageons de retenir des crimes
majeurs comme la sédition et la
conspiration
pas plus tard qu'hier notre bureau a
organisé une cellule composée de
procureurs de la sécurité nationale de
très haut niveau et de procureurs de la
corruption publique dont les seuls
ordres de marche de ma part son de
monter des accusations de sédition et de
conspiration liée aux actes les plus
odieux qui ont eu lieu au capitole
il s'agit d'accusations importante qui
comporte des crimes avec des peines de
prison allant jusqu'à 20 ans dans la
peine prononcée ce lundi contre un homme
originaire de floride est reconnu
coupable d'être entrée à l'intérieur du
sénat le 6 janvier dernier les
procureurs avaient d'abord retenu le
fait qu'il avait participé à une menace
contre la démocratie
mais il ne s'agit pas à proprement
parler d'un terme juridique et c'est
finalement pour obstruction à une
procédure officielle puisqu'il avait
participé à l'interruption du décompte
du collège électoral que cet homme a
écopé d'une peine de 8 mois de prison
une affaire qui pourrait faire
jurisprudence pour tous les autres
participants à cette manifestation qui
comme lui sont certes entrer à
l'intérieur du capitole mais n'ont
commis aucune violence
[Musique]
il y a donc encore plusieurs centaines
de cas à étudier pour la justice des
dossiers qui devraient être abordés
pendant l'été et au cours de l'automne
avec évidemment différents dossiers
selon le niveau d'implication selon s'il
a été fait usage de la violence ou non
le fbi elle se montre particulièrement
sévère et publie régulièrement des
vidéos qui suivent à chaque fois le
dossier d'un accusé en particulier pour
illustrer les méfaits commis par
certains notamment donc l'usagé de la
violence contre des agents de police des
faits qualifiés de terrorisme par le fbi
cette attaque ce siège était un
comportement criminel pur et simple et
c'est un comportement que nous le fbi
haye
considérons comme du terrorisme
domestique il n'a pas sa place dans
notre démocratie et le tolérer
reviendrait à se moquer de l'état de
droit de notre nation la difficulté pour
la justice américaine sera donc de
prononcer des peines proportionnées pour
chacun des accusés selon qu'il est
simplement pris les selphy à l'intérieur
du capitole ou qu'ils aient attaqué un
agent de police mais en qualifiant cette
attaque comme du terrorisme
voire même comme la pire attaque contre
la démocratie américaine depuis la
guerre civile selon les mots du
président américain joe biden
les autorités ouvrent la voie à des
peines exemplaires est particulièrement
lourde
rajoutez à cela une commission d'
enquête parlementaire menée par les
démocrates et décrié et vous avez un
sentiment qui domine chez une partie des
républicains que ces procès auront une
portée éminemment politique tout cela
risque d'aggraver la fracture déjà
béante de la société américaine et que
cette attaque du siège janvier dernier
ici au capitole a tristement illustré
alors que ces dernières semaines se sont
enchaînés les catastrophes naturelles
près de 200 pays se réunissent à partir
de demain pour évoquer les nouvelles
prévisions des experts sur le climat de
l'onu
en ligne de mire la coop 26 qui se
déroulera en novembre
depuis le dernier rapport d'évaluation
du giec en 2014 la situation climatique
s'est nettement dégradée regardez
[Musique]
e
oh
m
[Musique]
oh
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi prochain journal à 21h à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
des militaires français dans certains
essaient savait qu'il pourrait y avoir
des conséquences très graves sur la
population et pourtant ils ont mené les
essais nucléaires au moins lors d'un
essai l'essai centaure qui a eu lieu le
17 juillet 1974 l'ensemble de la
population polynésienne a été exposé
bien au delà de ce millisieverts cette
population là ne connaissait absolument
rien du nucléaire donc il a été très
facile pour l'état pendant des années de
nous vendre la thèse des essais propre
la ministre de la mémoire et des anciens
combattants geneviève darrieussecq à
elle dit que la france n'avait pas
commis de mensonges d'état qu'est ce
qu'on peut répondre à cela
c'est totalement totalement surréaliste
pour moi elle n'est pas un ministre de
la mémoire avec les ministres de
l'amnésique le président lui-même a
reconnu qu'il y avait eu ce mensonge
d'état